you know we mentioned offline this idea
of bringing people back to life
through um through artificial
intelligence
sort of i don't know if you've seen
videos of
basically animating people back to life
meaning uh whether it's for me
personally i've been working
on specifically about albert einstein
but also alan turing
isaac newton and richard feynman
and it's an opportunity to bring people
that meant a lot
to others in the world and uh
animate them and be able to have a
conversation with them
uh at first to try to visually
visually explore the the full
richness of character that they had as
they struggle with the ideas of the
modern age
sort of it's less about bringing back
their mind
and more bringing back the the visual
quirks that made them who they are
and then maybe in the future it's using
the textual the visual the
the the video the audio data to actually
compress down the person for who they
are and be able to generate texts
there's a few companies
there's replica which is a chat engine
that was born out of the idea of
bringing
the founder uh lost her friend
uh to uh he he got ran over by a car
and the initial reason she founded the
company was
trying to just have a conversation with
her friend she trained
a machine learning uh natural language
system
on the text that they exchanged with
each other and try she had a
conversation with him
sort of after he was gone uh and it's
very
the the conversation was very trivial it
was obvious that it's
uh you know a ai agent but it
gave her solace it made her actually
feel really good
and that's the way i wonder if it's
possible to bring back
people that are that means something to
us personally not just einstein but
people that we've lost and in that way
achieve a kind of small artificial
immortality i don't know if you think
about this kind of stuff
uh well i'd definitely think about a lot
of things that that one's a really good
one there's a great black mirror episode
about the
the wife who brings back the the
boyfriend or husband
i think one of the challenges with
bringing back richard feynman would be
to
to capture his sense of humor but that
would be awesome um but yeah bringing
back loved ones would be great
especially if uh if it's
your they're young and uh they die
early though it may hold you back from
moving on that's another
thing that could happen as a negative
but i think that's great and i also
think that it's going to be possible
especially when we're recording some of
us every aspect of our lives whether
it's
our face or uh things we see right
eventually one day everything we see can
be recorded
and then you can you can build
somebody's experience
and and thoughts uh speech and and you
will have
replicas of everybody um at least
digitally
and physically you could do that too one
day but that that's a
good idea especially because there are
people that i'd like to meet and i think
it's easier than building a time machine
one person i'd love to meet is benjamin
franklin really well
i wouldn't go back in time um i would
but i'd prefer to bring him into the
future and say
can you believe we have this thinking
machine in our pockets now
and he just see the look on his face as
to where humanity has come because i
think of him as a modern guy
that just was before his time yeah so
you're
you're thinking benjamin franklin the
scientist not benjamin flanken the
political thing because he'd be very
upset with congress right now
right so maybe talk to him about science
and technology not
uh not politics or maybe just don't get
him on twitter because he'll be very
upset with human civilization
you know i i wonder what their
personalities are like isaac newton it
does seem
complicated to figure out what their
personality is like even friedrich
nietzsche who i also thought about
feynman is we just have enough video
where we get the full kind of i mean it
shows you
how important it is to get not the
official
kind of book level presentation of a
human but the authentic
the full spectrum of humanity you
mentioned collecting data
about a person collecting the whole
thing the
whole of life the ups and downs the
embarrassing stuff the beautiful stuff
not just the things that's condensed
into a book and then with finding you
start to see that a little bit
through conversations you start to see
peaks of like that genius
and then through stories about him from
others
and then certainly you uh the the sad
thing about alan turing for example
is there's very little if any
uh recording of him in fact i haven't
been able to find recording allegedly
there's supposed to be a recording of
him
uh doing some kind of uh radio broadcast
but i haven't been able to find anything
and so that that's that's that's truly
sad that it feels like it makes you
realize
how the upside how nice it is to collect
data
about a person to capture that person
there's that's the upside of the modern
internet age the digital age
that that information and yeah creates a
kind of immortality
the and then you can choose to highlight
the best parts of the person maybe throw
away the
ugly parts and uh celebrate them even
after they're gone
so that's a really interesting
opportunity
you